y nos preguntan qué hora es bien lo que
tenemos que hacer es localizar la
manecilla horario la que indica las
horas que es esta que está aquí la que
es más corta y observar hacia dónde
apunta bien si recordamos esta es la
carátula de nuestro reloj e iniciamos
contando a las doce en punto que es esta
marca que está aquí arriba y luego sería
la un en punto las dos en punto las tres
en punto cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve diez así que el horario está
apuntando a las diez las diez horas
ahora tenemos que observar hacia dónde
apunta el minutero la manecilla larga la
que está aquí y recordamos que cada
marca indica cinco minutos e inicia en
esta marca arriba a los cero minutos
después de la hora así que son cero
minutos después de la hora cinco minutos
después de la hora y es justo donde está
apuntando el minutero así que son las 10
horas con 5 minutos
muy bien hagamos más ejercicios bien qué
hora es
vamos a ver hacia dónde apunta el
horario la manecilla corta entonces
empezamos en la marca de las 12 horas en
punto
y nos vamos a la una dos tres
y 4 pero observamos que la manecilla
horario aún no llega al 4 lo que nos
indica que siguen siendo las 3 horas
escribimos 3 y ahora observemos a la
manecilla larga el minutero que está
apuntando exactamente a esta marca y
recordamos que cada marca equivale a 5
minutos y empieza a los 0 minutos
después de la hora exactamente en esta
marca aquí arriba entonces son 0 minutos
después de la hora cinco minutos después
de la obra diez minutos después de la
hora 15 20 25 30 35 40 45 eso quiere
decir que son las 3 horas con 45 minutos
lo escribimos y comprobamos nuestra
respuesta muy bien
se está poniendo bueno esto es vamos al
siguiente qué hora es
una vez más observemos la manecilla
horario la que es corta que está aquí y
vemos que se está acercando a la marca
de las 12 horas en punto pero aún no ha
llegado eso quiere decir que son las 11
horas
1 - antes de las 12 horas en punto si
esta es la marca de las 11 son las 11
horas
muy bien y el minutero hacia donde
apunta bueno otra vez está apuntando
hacia esta marca que está aquí dijimos
que para el caso de los minutos cada una
de las marcas equivale a cinco minutos y
se empieza a contar desde arriba desde
la marca superior que son cero minutos
después de la hora cinco minutos después
de la hora diez minutos después de la
hora 15 20 25 30 35 40 45 las 1145
comprobamos eso muy bien vamos al
siguiente nos vuelven a preguntar qué
hora es
observamos hacia dónde apunta el horario
la manecilla corta la manecilla corta
está entre estas dos marcas muy bien
veamos cuáles son recordemos que estas
son las 12 horas en punto la una en
punto las dos en punto las tres en punto
las cuatro en punto las cinco en punto y
las seis en punto el horario está entre
las cinco en punto y las seis en punto
pero aún no llega al 6
más cercano al 5 y mientras no llegue al
6 y lo rebase seguirán siendo las 5
horas
así que escribimos 5 es tiempo de ver
hacia dónde apunta el minutero el
minutero es la manecilla larga y está
apuntando a esta marca
dijimos empezamos aquí arriba con 0
minutos después de la hora cinco minutos
después de la obra diez minutos después
de la hora quince minutos después de la
hora y veinte minutos después de la hora
muy bien quiere decir que son las cinco
horas con 20 minutos lo escribimos y
comprobamos eso muy bien
vamos a hacer el último
una vez más que ahora es bien observamos
el horario la manecilla corta que esta
vez está apuntando así esta marca a ver
vamos a ver yo pienso que es el 9 pero
vamos a comprobarlo las 12 horas en
punto la una las 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
efectivamente el 9 pero si vemos todavía
no llega a las 9 horas está ligeramente
atrás de la marca de las 9 horas por lo
que son las 8 horas muy bien
ahora observamos el minutero la
manecilla larga la manecilla larga está
exactamente en esta marca vamos a ver
cuál es dijimos que los minutos empiezan
aquí en esta marca superior a los 0
minutos después de la obra y cada marca
equivale a 5 minutos entonces tenemos 0
5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40 45 50 55 son 55
minutos después de la hora las 855 muy
bien comprobamos nuestra respuesta muy
bien